is there anything else you want to say
when you saw the speech like did you see
that speech saying there was 10 percent
of it that was good it was you know this
part of it that was good because one
party is talking mega the other part is
i'm not just the president for the
democrats i'm a democrat president for
the left and the right and the middle i
want to be the president for everybody
you can't say that but at the same time
you take shots
yeah an organization again
i want to be respectful of american
americans so i can only say i was just
personally deeply distressed as an
observer from the other side of the
world as i see america as a leader of
the free world and critical to our
future
and i i loathe division i do i hate the
idea of of of division so what i saw was
yes some appeal to some higher ideals
but that was to sort of almost set up
the attack on
people who have a different set of
opinions as apparently being responsible
for smashing those ideals
rather than to say how can we sit down
and talk through uh and recommit to
those ideas i found myself thinking this
is a surprisingly fluent speech because
i haven't seen a lot of fluent speeches
you know i usually see the cards or we
hear him repeating bits that are on the
autocue a genuine question would he have
had some sort of device there for
autocues screens in front because it was
quite fluent
yeah i think you make a great point here
and i'm going to give a couple different
perspectives here
i hear so many people basically saying
joe biden can't speak anymore
okay he's got dementia he can't even get
words out of his mouth he was pretty
clear for an hour
people understood what he was saying
it's 22 minutes okay so a half hour
almost point is he gave a long speech so
on one side of things people are saying
he can't speak he's in the basement
hiding well he's out there
um i don't think it was necessarily a
a speech that will live in infamy
however this is the thing that he's
missing
donald trump and the mag of republicans
are a threat to the very soul of this
country
okay magga is the new republican party
okay what's donald trump's approval
ratings within the republican party 90
tyler you would know this it's close to
90. okay so
the republican party
that
that we knew the george w bush previous
republican dick cheney you know that
establishment that doesn't exist anymore
that's gone but does the republican
party of truman and clinton democratic
party of truman and clinton exist
anymore
arguably they would not but but
specifically about the republicans
the the old republican guard does not
exist the liz cheney's of the world adam
kinders of the world the dick cheney's
of the world the mitt romney's of the
world the george w bush
gone
this is trump's party
whether it's good or bad
he controls the party so what biden is
missing is quote unquote the mag of
republicans or that that is the new
republican party
it's not a fringe element of the
republicans so your point is that it
really is an attack on a vast number of
that's what i'm saying is that 80
million people voted for
trump and of that
of the republicans
75 million people is who we're talking
about here so it's a mixed messaging so
that's maybe what he i don't know
clearly somebody was telling him what to
say wrote to speech what have you but
that is the most that is what resonates
the most with me about this is that the
misunderstanding that the republican
party is now the maga party the previous
party is now gone the rhinos gone
you know when's the only time a speech
like this works
when you know for a fact you have a big
lead
you can't talk like this when you don't
have a lead he doesn't have a lead
you have to try to
show a different side
you can't talk like this when you don't
have a lead he does not have a lead so
it's got to come from a different angle
it's got to come from an angle to try to
win people over you know
when i when i left when i started out in
politics
my predecessor in my i think i don't
know what you'd call a district i think
but in my electorate he was a wise man a
very good man
and he said now but as you kick off john
there's something you need to understand
he said half the people who vote you
voted for you will love you
and half the people that voted for you
won't
they voted for you yeah and half of
people didn't vote for you will hate you
but half of them will actually think
you're a very good person
don't
antagonize the people who did not vote
for you many of them will have different
perspectives and they may not have been
able to put your their tick against your
name but they're fine australian yes i
fully agree with that i agree and you
said this is what distressed me about
the speech as a former practice look i'm
just from a little country and i was
only the deputy i wasn't the president
of the united states but i look at it as
a really concerned
deeply committed
person when it comes to democracy and
freedom and i think this guy's what he
says is
words are bullets
and there are all those americans out
there who voted for
i just don't think trump was the problem
as people say
uh so much as the product of the problem
if you've got fellow americans who feel
so alienated so left behind
so
[Music]
um uh dismissed by today's elites
including we were talking about
capitalism
you know the the the the tech
billionaires are squinters who seem to
be quite contentious of little people
it's as though they're the problem they
want their plasma tvs and their jet skis
and their chevy suburbans and they're
the enemy of the par you know the planet
so while i get wealthier and i'm not
going to give up any of my lifestyle and
i'll jet around the world to climate
claims conferences and i'll live in a
you know in a mansion and i'll have
several holiday houses scattered around
the world and i'm a global citizen
you people who by the way just happened
to feed me and keep the transportation
system working and educate my kids and
police the streets you're just scum
you're the enemy
that sort of contempt
is
extant in all of our countries i'm not
singling out the united states please
don't hear me say that i'm saying i
think it's a real problem for social
harmony and democracy depends upon
social harmony depends on trust it
depends on respect for the other person
when you have a debate it should be as
fierce as you like i mean i've listened
with respect to what patrick's saying in
you know with with all cranny because so
yeah i'm sorry keep going um and
you know we don't have to agree on
everything right but we can we're going
to have a fierce argument on the things
we might disagree on but in the end
we're fellow human beings
right and if we lose sight of that
and if some people are scum they're the
enemy and gay or the goddess earth or
whatever we start to paint them that way
no wonder they're going to hit out so
what's the commander in chief's job to
do make sure he's actually got his army
behind him not a great slab of them
wanting to
you know overturn the system so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right
you